[Wil] Bladesmiths,
welcome to the Forge.
In every one
of these competitions,
we have four bladesmiths
walk through that door,
but oftentimes
there's the presence
of a fifth, unnamed bladesmith.
[dramatic music playing]
Big BLU.
[Bryce]
What on earth are we gonna do
with this giant piece
of history right here?
[Wil] This Big BLU power hammer
has facilitated the success
of almost every single
Forged in Fire champion
that's walked through
that door.
On the other hand, it has
literally chewed up
and spit out the dreams
of other bladesmiths...
Oh man!
...turning
their forge experience
into an absolute nightmare.
Well, now it's time to replace
and retire Big BLU.
But not before we rip out
its beating heart
and turn that high carbon piston
into four competition choppers
that fall between 11 and 13
inches in length.
Your blades at the end
of this round
must not exceed
22 inches overall.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
Your time starts now.
[Bryce] We only have three hours
to take the thing apart
and make a knife?
That's insane.
[Colton] We all decide
we're gonna work
together to take this apart.
It'll benefit all of us.
It's really a testament to the
competitorship we have here...
We're coming. She's going.
...when you watch these guys
help one another
disassemble that machine
very quickly.
We know we're all working
off the same piece of steel.
There's no working
against each other.
We gotta get this thing off.
[dramatic rock music playing]
[Bryce] We all have
an even amount of steel
to make a knife
to meet parameters.
That's about a one-
and-three-eighths-inch shaft.
[Colton] When the steel
finally gets up to temperature,
I start squishing
the steel down.
I'm pretty optimistic about how
fast I can get this to run out.
I just purchased a press
about a week ago
so I have a little bit
of experience.
But up until that point,
I've basically just depended
on these guys right here.
[Craig] On the whole,
my progress is doin' well.
But I'm definitely the old guy
in the room.
It's me against
three younger guys
that, uh, are probably a little
more physically fit than me.
But maybe I'm a little more
mentally fit than them.
[Wil] One hour has elapsed.
You have two hours remaining
to finish your work.
I realize after about
two passes through Big BLU
I'm spending too much time
on Big BLU itself.
I'm not letting my metal
heat up as fast.
So time is ticking by because
I'm not really moving metal.
It looks like Bryce has some
maybe different thicknesses
on his blade.
You can see there are
dark spots
and then there are spots that
are holding a little more heat.
[David] It's sitting under
the actual burner
and he's not moving that steel
back and forth, evening it out.
[Colton] After I get
profiling done,
I get ready to drill some holes
for the pins
in the next round.
Colton is over here
using a punch
as he kinda marks some holes
for his tang.
[David] That's smart work.
I do this now because
in the next round,
it will be quenched and hard
and sometimes you can't drill
holes in hardened steel.
[Wil] The blades
are coming along.
We should have some
beautiful competition choppers
in the next hour or so.
Right now, I'm just gonna go
grind the handle a bit more,
tweak it,
uh, shorten it up,
and then we'll be good
to start quenching.
I'm thinking, "Wow.
I have never used a grinder
like this before."
This shop compared to mine
blows mine outta the water.
It feels a little odd
using other people's tools
but you just gotta roll
with the punches.
Before I heat treat,
I definitely am thermocycling
that blade.
Now I gotta make sure there's
not gonna be any cracking
or tinging or warps
when I put it in that oil.
Quenching!
-Quenching?
-Not bad. That was a good color.
[David] Good job. Look at that.
Looks pretty straight from here.
[Bryce] It looks amazing.
I'm pumped right now. Let's go.
[dramatic music playing]
[Wil] Over here, we got a quench
outta Colton.
[Colton] I'm feeling pretty good
with this quench.
Five, four, three, two, one!
Bladesmiths, shut down
your machines! Drop your tools!
This first round of competition
is over!
Bladesmiths,
welcome to our strength test:
the bamboo chop.
This tough, springy material
is not only gonna test the edge
of your blades,
but it's gonna test the overall
construction of your knife.
This is gonna be a lot of fun.
At least for me.
Colton, you're up first.
-How you feeling?
-Good.
Good? I feel good too.
Let's go.
[dramatic music playing]
[Colton] I know J. hits
really, really hard.
So I'm a little nervous
that the amount of force
he's gonna put into that
might make the blade just snap
in half when he hits the bamboo.
[grunting]
[dramatic rock music playing]
[tense music playing]
Nice job, Colton.
Edge held up well.
You fixed that little warp
so everything stayed lined up.
The handle, would've liked to
have been beefed up a little.
That's on the narrow side.
But overall, good job.
Thank you.
Hey, Bryce. How you doing?
-Doing good.
-Gonna make Big BLU proud?
-I am.
-[J.] Let's see.
[dramatic music playing]
[Bryce] Soon as J. grabs
my blade, I was like, "Wow."
I'm worried my blade's
a little bit thin
so I'm hoping it doesn't crack
or splinter off.
[grunting]
[dramatic rock music playing]
Nice work, Bryce.
It's not the prettiest knife
I've ever seen.
But your edge held up fine.
Your handle, little bit long.
Kinda simple.
But overall, good job.
Thank you.
And then there was Craig.
-How you feeling, bud?
-Feeling good. Ready to go.
All right. Let's see
how your knife feels.
-Let's do it.
-[dramatic music playing]
[Craig] As I watch
the other tests going on,
I'm just kinda getting
more amped up.
I'm ready for it.
But you cannot make
those butterflies settle down.
[grunting]
[dramatic rock music playing]
[tense music playing]
-[J.] It survived!
-[laughs]
-[J.] Good job, Craig.
-Thank you.
The edge is perfect.
Nothing wrong with it.
I like the look of it,
the feel of it.
-Overall, did a very good job.
-Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths.
This is our sharpness test:
the rope bridge slice.
Unlike the strength test,
this is all about what the edge
of your weapon
will do to the rope.
-Colton, you're first. Ready?
-Yep.
Let's do this.
[tense music playing]
Man. Good cutting.
Good cut.
All right, Colton, let's talk
about your chopper here.
Nice and clean lines.
Shiny. And more importantly,
one and done for every slice.
It will cut.
-Bryce, your turn. Ready?
-I'm ready.
Let's do this.
[tense music playing]
-Yeah.
-Good job.
Good job. Good job.
Well, Bryce...
I think that Bryce is right.
[laughs]
Your edge is sharp.
Your handle construction here
does tend to be a little bit
shallow right there
to where it allows my hand
to fall forward
and there's a little bit
big space right there.
But most of all, sir...
it will cut.
Thank you.
-All right, old timer.
-[chuckles]
-You ready for this?
-Ready as I'm getting.
Let's do this.
[Craig] The first two blades go
and they slice perfectly
and all I'm expecting to see
is my knife bounce
right off that rope.
[tense music playing]
[grumbles]
[laughs]
All right, Craig.
What is there not to like?
It's got a nice curved edge
to when you're swinging it,
I can feel the curve
and it slices nicely.
And most of all, sir...
it will cut.
Wow. Thank you very much.
[tense music playing]
Bladesmiths,
in these deliberations
the judges have to consider
not just how your blades
performed in the tests
but also feel, fit, and finish.
They've made
their final decision.
It's time for one of you smiths
to leave the Forge.
[tense music playing]
Bryce, your blade
did not make the cut.
[Doug] Bryce, you did great.
But all the blades
performed equally.
It came down to your handle.
Your handle, in comparison, was
a little larger than the others.
It was a good, better, best.
Yours was good,
but the others
were better and best.
For that reason,
we're sending you home.
I understand.
Bryce, please surrender
your blade.
[Bryce] I do 100% agree
with the judges.
I respect their opinions
on my blade.
This was a great competition.
I'm not disappointed
in myself.
My blade held up
to all the tests.
I came here to prove
that I can
compete with
other bladesmiths out there.
I definitely believe
I proved it.